all right I've got a weak offensive line
no depth on defense and a new coach who
says he knows Aaron Rodgers it's not
what I ordered I thought you could cook
anything dad thinks you could turn the
Bronco around but I already flamed out
in the big time Seattle behind we are
behind Chef how's the old Judy it's it's
simmering thank you Chef Corner yes you
know Russ you might get further with
people if you stopped acting so extra
all the time hurt Chef hey man uh look
we made another mistake of friend zone
what's up Scott Bronco
calm down service isn't for another two
hours two minutes coach people already
lined up ten nine eight dark brown Five
Point nothing you got your bubble water
and your fancy headphones why are you in
charge of the restaurant
fire fire everything fired already
remember separation comes from
preparation whatever you say Chef I want
all the beef the new special looks like
it could be really good sorry that's not
for like four to six months looks like
you're sticking with the usual fun Chef
that's it well we couldn't finish it all
so I set over three
how are you gonna make a bear parody and
I make it about the Bears we're also
miserable people trying to make it work
in Chicago
SMH I hate this more than I hate the
fans I mean
foreign